I use percolator because that's what we
use in Italy and somebody told me that
it burns the coffee because the waters
boy boy shows a carcinogenic
[Music]
you
you
you
which one of your exes would you like to
go back and sleep with probably my first
pop boyfriend from when I was about 16
17 because I mean we didn't know
anything then we were really young and
I'm just a lot better at sex now I think
he probably would be too and I wonder if
that would have changed anything would
you keep him as a 16 year old
[Music]
okay which colleague or professional
contact would you like to apologize to
do you remember when I had that
secretary job after uni I just couldn't
handle getting all of these invoices and
like contracts my desk cuz I just didn't
know what to do with them and eventually
just really start to stress me out so I
just used to shred everything no no
because I I left the job after three
months and also I misses I also you know
everybody on the mailing list saying I'm
only here for the money
I'm going down to put the tickets to
Vietnam now but I meant to send it to my
cousin but I sent it to every
professional contact oh yeah no I do I
do for that actually but this there was
a family friend who got me the job I
think should have apologized way sooner
that should
who is the most unlikely or unusual
person you've masturbated oh god it's
probably yeah
a teacher I don't if I can even remember
her name
mrs. Warnock just you know when I was
still finding finding my feet
masturbation in what way do you think
you might be described as bad in bed by
an uncharitable person
the fun never starts Jake my mind tends
to wander work has someone called you
out for that yes many times
what did you just post and listen to me
well I cuz if I have a thought then I
need to attend to it immediately so I'll
be like yeah so I just need to send his
emails and his texts normally take this
cool so yeah how long it's explore you
can take time off in the middle yeah
well this buzz was um charitable so yes
this going on for a world and it's good
to know that I'm I can call you at any
time and
[Laughter]
and what about you does your partner not
understand nothing you understand me
[Laughter]
but I know it's come up recently I do
feel that yeah when I'm flirting
I am known to be quite a flirty person
and obviously I've got little male
friends and I think sometimes you you
get really possessive really possessive
sorry I don't look good but but you know
and I think it's important for my senses
autonomies my senses potency too and you
know feel desired by more people than
just you yeah I think that's it I do
find it the cool I don't really have
lots of female friends maybe that's it
and I just like I guess just find it
weird to know whether the line is good I
like if you've let it more I mean not
with you can flirt with me laughs yeah
but would make me feel like you are
actually desirable
at the School of Life we believe in
developing emotional intelligence to
that end we've also created a whole
range of products to support that growth
find out more at the link on the screen
now
you